you
hi everyone is cheering January 11th
1886 was when Game one of the first
World Chess Championship match was
played between Johannes a sucker tour
playing on the white end in this one and
Wilhelm steinitz Steines went on to win
this match 10 wins - 5 wins
didn't count the draws for this match by
the way it was a first to win 10 games
and you're the champion is this
something we should be doing nowadays
not counting the draws I think there'd
be many votes yes to that anyhow I think
it'd be interesting for us to observe
how the game was played over 130 years
ago let's see a sucker tore opening with
deform Steines replying with d5 we have
a Slav defense with III now this gives
us some indication of the type of
opening to be played a pretty quiet
beginning non-confrontational and we
actually don't see our first capture
until move 16 and that capture is
actually a sacrifice
Bishop f5 deploying the bishop outside
of the pawn chain minor pieces coming
out a3 is not designed to prevent a pin
but rather to expand on the Queen side
with c5 and then b4 this is not a good
idea we know this now to release the
tension in the center to release this
pressure against d5 is not a good idea
this gives black an easier time playing
'if I've this is rock solid on d5 this
is a perfect defender so the epon is no
longer needed
he's free to move and he should
after b4e five hits now what will he do
from a five it's to be determined maybe
a push maybe capture maybe he keeps
white guessing for just a little bit
more Bishop e2 Knight to f6 they played
a total of 20 games in this match by the
way and they jumped around just a little
bit throughout the states the first five
games so this game and the next four
games were played in New York City and
then the next four after that were
played in st. Louis and the remaining
eleven games were played in New Orleans
anyhow continuing we have Bishop b2 b4
it is so a locked Center Black has space
on the kingside White has space on the
queenside each will play where they have
space Knight d2 h4 Sumi h5 is supporting
a Knight g4 move this is negated with h3
and it's important white does this so
ignoring a knight hop into g4 with let's
say Queen c2 preparing to queenside
castle well now once he's there he can't
be dislodged so easily with h3 now
because there's a Queen h4 move there's
a pin there's pressure on f2 h3 does
there will be no Knight g4 I believe
this is going to be the only pop-quiz I
throw your way what does a Steinitz do
in this position what is Stein it's his
idea from this position if you'd like to
go ahead pause the video what does black
do next okay well in the game
Knight to Fe this isn't a moment to say
well we should castle in fact neither
player it's interesting note in the
first game of the first World Chess
Championship ramp the first game ever
World Chess Championship match play
neither player castled it's not
important in this position to castle we
have a lock center there's more
important things to do
Knight f8 it is making use of FA g6
where is he trying to go he's trying to
get into g2 trying to put pressure on
this point white continues on the
queenside knight g6 is this going to be
prevented nope white continues with b5
now if it is prevented this is blacks
next move Knight h4 if that move was
prevented with g3 how to make some
forward progress just want to give you a
little bit of insight as to how black
could try and tackle a position like
this where you know these pawns are
covering a lot of ground how do you make
one of them flinch well you could begin
with thrown a jab at h3 that's difficult
to defend you'd have to run in reverse
to defend and then there could be this
idea Knight h7 into g5 and finally he's
gonna have to budge and when he does
black could then operate on the g4
square that doesn't happen in the game
white simply ignores Knight to h4 b5
Knight h4 only now in g3 and what to do
with the night well he's not going
backwards he's going in
- G - where there is now no escape that
hits with check King f1 he can't be
defended so what's the idea
move 16 first capture and it's a sac
giving up the night for two ponds and a
big attack still a lot of pieces around
two bishops a knight a rook that's ready
to do a rover this is the only guy
that's not going to contribute in the
attack he's not needed this is plenty so
let's see how white tries to defend this
King G - bishop just gets out of harm's
way Queen f1 is best at this stage but
Queen g1 is play it easy to go wrong for
white
now we have Brooke h6
preparing to win the queen
he's trying to bolt go towards the
queenside but this is too much rook g6
Queen to d7 how are you defending h3
there's no good defense of h3 like first
inserts a capture and c6 what to do
about h3 nothing if you tried to defend
like this well that's embarrassing just
got your queen trapped so rook g1 the
computer's eyes this is best black picks
up a third pawns so there isn't even a
material and bounce really it's three
pawns for the night plenty and the
attack continues King e1 Knight g4 he's
taken out Knight to e2 looking at the f4
square Queen sneaks over Knight f4 one
little punch at the rook easily
sidestepped he's going to be dislodged
soon enough after Bishop c3 tough to
recommend anything for white here I'm
not sure what the purpose is exactly of
Bishop c3 he is certainly a bit more
vulnerable being on an open file at some
stage rook to b8 can hit maybe trying to
come here to defend tough to say
here comes g5 Knights flush back the
rook enters so this isn't an this is an
open file for white but this little rook
up and over it's really like an open
file for black now the rook is very
active and sneaks right in immediately
into the white position rook f3 if he's
captured there's a recapture within a
fork that will be collapsing fast for
white the rook isn't captured in this
game instead III is defended rook to b8
King to D - and here comes just this
tsunami of pawns on the Kings side
preparing an f5 break a5 Irish time you
have 4 break a 5 f4 is now in rook h3
and what's the idea with Queen f7 to get
to the second rank so a timely capture
with rook to f2 is the idea
rook e1 and here we go pawn takes pawn
Knight takes pawn rook f2 what to do
with the Queen no good solution here for
white
in the game sucker tour gives up the
Queen for the rook doing something else
Queen 2g1 is the only other save square
look at all the ground the black pieces
are covering all these squares are taken
out by the bishop the rooks so if Queen
g1 there would be Queen f3 and you're
not defending that Knight any further
hit three times defended twice so Queen
takes rook in the game Queen takes Queen
of course y can resign at this stage
this was another interesting thing to
know about this game not only didn't did
neither player castle in this game but
you know the game continues when it's
you know completely dead oh I could have
resigned to many many many moves ago but
plays on for a little bit more so let's
see how this one finishes up and have a
little bit of a king walk and Bishop
takes pawn Bishop takes Bishop there
isn't really anything to really know
from this point on ok a little a little
check if the rook is captured there'd be
a fork black could actually allow
something like this and still be winning
but a simple block at this stage move 46
and White has had enough at this point
white resigns so I thought just thought
it'd be interesting to share this game
with you
the first world chess championship game
between these two modest opening we saw
that playing c5 was just not a good idea
releasing the pressure in the center on
d5 a lot black a free hand to play e5
and then play on the side of the board
where each had some space the first
capture on move 16 was in fact a
sacrifice and a very favorable attack
for black so if we have a look at the
tale of the tape with this one
interesting to see what computers say
about how this game was played sucker
tour with Eden accuracies six mistakes
two blunders an average sent upon loss
of 56 steinitz with three and accuracies
four mistakes and 0 blunders average
sent upon loss of 31 and that's just a
quick glance of the evaluation
throughout this 46 mover
so anyhow feel free as usual to leave
any feedback to this video in the
comment section below and I'll catch you
in the next one that's all for now take
care bye
you